one of my favorite shows actually I love
Eurovision Eurovision Eurovision 2023.
oh my God how was it how is it being a
part of that state just insane I don't
you grew up on it yeah yeah totally
great yeah I'm from musical theater yeah
because I love Eurovision too with Will
Ferrell and Rachel yeah but they got
that spot on yeah I know but that's why
I loved it yeah yeah but that's what
you're amazing is incredible guys
oh my God I love them and then back in
the day we had bucks Fizz I mean which
would never happen now yeah like four uh
four people group and two girls and one
part of the song the guys whip the girls
skirts off and they've got like Minis
and I was like can you imagine a woman
going oh no that's cool yeah let's do it
oh my God I know but I think that's
what's so funny like the and not funny
but just entertaining is like how
outrageous it can get the best part even
like modern skin like it's they're
outrageous in the way that they look
like they're first of all in a Vogue
shoot yeah all the time it's very
theatrical but like but they're attire
like their aesthetic is cool and the
songs are rad like yeah I mean obviously
like Abba Celine Dion there's so many
winners
I absolutely I mean Celine Dion yeah God
what we would have given to hear her
sing back then with that I mean just
incredible yeah so it's been quite
overwhelming but I'd never worked with
an in-ear I do guitar I am not the
person I you know what I do this
yeah you go like I look up and I'm just
like I hate I literally
I was like please don't do that
it's not good it's not good for me
either I don't it's I don't do well I
have to stop myself going sorry 180
million people what yeah awful yeah I I
didn't get used to it I didn't at all
and then the crowd gets so loud and
you're like it almost sounds like
Charlie Brown's teacher
saying and we're on live television
anyway it was a hit
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going home